la capitale soudanaise compose avec des
coups de feu des explosions et des
colonnes de fumées depuis ce matin
explosion qui se font entendre jusque
dans ces studios de télévision et qui
ont forcé l'interruption d'un bulletin
de nouvelles ces violences sont le
résultat d'affrontement entre le groupe
paramilitaire de soutien rapides Soudan
et l'armée régulière les paramilitaires
ont déclaré cette emparée du palais
présidentiel que la résidence du chef de
l'armée ainsi que de l'aéroport de
cartoon et de ceux des villes de Meroë
et elle adebes l'armée pour sa part
Annie et la prise de l'aéroport de la
capitale mais confirme que des
paramilitaires s'ils sont infiltrés et
ont incendié des avions civils les deux
groupes mènent une lutte de pouvoir
depuis le coup d'État qui a fait tomber
en Marel Béchir en 2019 cette tension
palpable compromet les efforts pour
mener le Soudan vers un régime
démocratique alors qu'un accord de
sortie de crise a été signé en décembre
notamment par les généraux Mohamed
Hamdan dagalo à la tête des
paramilitaires et abdelfata Alboran
dirigeant de l'armée
de nombreux chefs de la diplomatie sur
la planète comme le secrétaire d'État
américain Anthony blinken réclame
l'arrêt des hostilités immédiatement
pour la sécurité de la population
une population restée à l'abri regardant
ce qui se passe par la fenêtre ou le
balcon comme le témoin les nombreuses
images captées par les citoyens
l'ambassadeur américain soudain le
décret d'ailleurs dans une publication
Twitter confirmant également qu'il s'est
mis à l'abri dans son ambassade ayant
peur d'une escalade de violence dans
d'autres régions soudanaises le Tchad a
annoncé la fermeture de sa frontière
commune avec son voisin les
paramilitaires seraient d'ailleurs déjà
tout prêt il revendique le contrôle
d'une base militaire dans le Darfour
occidental ici Carla Oliveira
Radio-Canada Montréal